now I do want to focus in on one
specific area of Donald Trump's 2019
budget Donald Trump wants to cut all
federal funding period a hundred percent
of it for PBS and for NPR that is a it's
a Public Broadcasting Service it is
National Public Radio and I want to
remind you of when Mitt Romney ran for
president against Barack Obama and he
talked about how as much as he loves Big
Bird of course referencing Sesame Street
which airs on PBS but he would also cut
federal funding for PBS remember this
moment from the debate a few years ago
well first of all I will eliminate all
programs by this test if they don't pass
it is the program so critical it's worth
borrowing money from China to pay for it
and if not I'll get rid of it Obamacare
is on my list I apologize mr. president
I use that term it with all respect I
like it good okay good so so I'll get
rid of that I'm sorry Jim I'm gonna stop
the subsidy to PBS I'm gonna stop other
things I like PBS I love big bird
actually like you too but I'm not gonna
I'm not gonna keep on spending money on
things to borrow money from China to pay
for us that's number one well right just
after that everybody with an ounce of
common sense realized wait a second not
only is federal spending on PBS a drop
in the bucket it's not even a drop in
the bucket of all federal spending some
people actually realized hey PBS and NPR
are actually pretty valuable in fact
they're so valuable that they create the
most informed news consumers out of all
media outlets in the United States if
you go back 10 years maybe even 15 years
study after study that measures how much
do people know relative to what their
primary source of news is PBS and NPR
create some of the most informed news
consumers in the United States which
kind of tells us everything we need to
know about why Trump wants to cut
funding to them right because the enemy
of Trump is informed people period and
Trump's new budget would end funding
period to the Corporation for Public
Broadcasting which is where the money
comes from for PBS and NPR now let's go
through the talking points of the
defenders of this tax cut some defenders
will say David come on listen
Trump's cutting a hundred percent of
federal funding for PBS and NPR but
federal funding is only a small portion
of all funding for PBS and NPR and
they're going to be fine
the problem is that funding for public
media has been on the decline already
for a long time and because of
demographic issues PBS and NPR generally
have older donors they've been hurt
because some of those viewers and
listeners have sort of put it bluntly
they've been dying off and the other
point is that just because federal
funding is a small portion of the total
NPR and PBS funding there are individual
stations and less privileged areas and
less populated areas that are much more
dependent on the federal funding here in
Boston we have the monster that is WGBH
where so much national PBS programming
originates WGBH is probably going to be
fine without the federal funding but the
PBS stations in the Midwest and in the
south and the NPR stations in the
mountain states those stations are much
more dependent on that federal funding
and this money overall actually has a
lot of importance this is a political
attack and this is why I said the budget
is a political document Trump benefits
from people not tuning into PBS and not
listening to NPR not because they are
partisan but because they do
investigative reporting period what can
be done I actually don't know I mean the
budget as I said needs to be approved by
Congress call your elected officials and
tell them don't cut funding for PBS and
NPR yeah I mean it may come down to
people just donating directly to the
Corporation for Public Broadcasting or
the cost of their budget that they get
from the the government is about five
hundred million dollars yeah which
really isn't that much that equals out
to about a dollar 37 per person yeah I'm
willing to pay that I know that you're
willing to pay that because this is very
valuable it's unbiased reporting from a
reputable source that's been around for
a long time and I think it should
continue when we're talking about
millions rather than billions in the
federal budget
we're probably already paying attention
to the wrong thing right we are talking
about a drop in the bucket and a
concerted effort to dumb down the
electorate to win votes period and we've
got to stop it
so call your elected officials tell them
you support funding you want an increase
in funding for PBS and NPR it's probably
a bad time for the David Pakman show to
apply for public funding yeah I know
we've never had public funding okay and
I think that that's one of the when I go
to stations that have lost programs that
depended on public funding I actually
tell them we don't depend on public
funding so you don't have to worry about
our program going away when Trump or
whoever decides to cut funding to the
David Pakman show that's a good thing
actually it is a good thing although we
still should fund PBS and NPR send me
your thoughts about this atrocity of a
budget I'm on Twitter at D Pakman we'll
be back after this today's episode of
the program is made possible in part by
brilliant which is really a fantastic
and unique online service that has sort
of reinvented the way people learn math
and science if you watch the show
you're already probably generally
curious about how the world works and
you like to learn new things maybe you
have a sort of casual interest in
physics or solar energy or AI philosophy
computer science but you're ready to
take it to the next level and whether
you already have a grasp on these
subjects or you want to engage and
acquaint yourself with these topics for
the first time brilliant is the place to
go you can actually learn hands-on by
solving problems and puzzles that were
designed by expert educators and
professionals and you can start right
now sign up for free at brilliant org
slash David Pakman the first 200 people
who visit brilliant org slash David
Pakman will get 20% off an annual
premium membership that is brilliant org
forward slash David Pakman